when you think about this i know you
have this idea of capitalism and
socialism end up being the same thing in
this environment explain what you mean
by that
because on a structural issue that you
have to have inflation and you don't
have a vote in a free free market just
ask again go back to
what would happen in a free market
prices would collapse to to
zero everywhere everything would
collapse
and so
so so we tell ourselves
we
we dismiss that because well we can't
let that happen
but that's the first principle answer
that's what would happen in a free free
market because this credit bubble
that that we live in
would unwind
and so we'd we we dismiss
what okay well it's kind of free
right there's no no kind of free and
then and then while you have manipulated
money
every price signal
has to be manipulated in fact as you
have manipulated money if if you have
min and money is just an abstract
concept for our time
people don't actually don't want more
money they want they think more money
will give them correct
and so so when you have misinformation
and money
which is the just the division of our
labor and it's all it is is trust
all over the world
wouldn't it be obvious that if you if
you are
trying to remove trust trying to give
misinformation and money you'd have
misinformation everywhere in society
and that's what's and that's what's
happening and and so to be able to
essentially and i don't want to call it
a crime
but
but be able to perpetu perpetuate that
lie
you have to control
you have to remove individual rights and
freedoms and drive more control
to perpetuate that lie
and and it comes from and and this the
probably the most frightening thing is
the people most hurt by that lie
um are the most susceptible to believing
in it and will vote to keep it going
because
because the thing that's hurting them
and transferring that wealth to to
to
the the 0.1 percent at an increasing
rate
um
and it's not they by the way it's not
the billionaires that are creating it
it's a system that's creating it the
billionaires are just
they what would you do
if you had asked that if you had your
choice of cash that was being devalued
would you put that into a house would
you put that into something else that
couldn't be devalued and if a country
was trying to stop you from doing that
you would move your assets to another
country
so every human human nature would say
i'm going to get this money out of here
to save it just like china's done to try
to move
their assets all around the world for
themselves for the same reason so that's
a structural issue
that's that's caused by this this is
printing money
but society votes for it
because
and again going back to that free market
just ask yourself a simple hypothetical
question if a politician today told you
the truth
and said listen here's what it looks
like i'm going to advocate for a free
market and i'm going to let all prices
collapse and and this is what it means
for everything
what i just said about no food on
shelves
banking failures and everything else
would you vote for them
like there's no one would vote for them
they'd be they would be ostracized so
so politicians are incented to lie
and and drive more and more inflation
which and and they're instead to say i'm
gonna help you poor per the person who's
been most hurt from this because of
those rich people
and they're going to print more money to
transfer more wealth
and and but they they have to now and
that's why you need a parallel system
like bitcoin
because this is this is a system global
system problem that can't solve it from
the system
it's impossible you have either complete
credit collapse or you have inflation
rate it keeps on it keeps on going and
and again
to
to measure this in months
when when this is playing out and it's
going to it's going to play out for a
long time it's going to people are going
to be
if there if there's a tightening
things will start collapsing really fast
and you can expect yield curve control
you can expect massive easing at some
point so if we're measuring at what
point i can't tell you it's just
but but essentially what you're what all
bets right now
are bets on
when government is going to stimulate
more correct nothing nothing else
matters right and so we don't live in a
free market we live in a
a bet on what's what's going to happen
with people stimulating
more
that's why a parallel system is required
because this system can't solve it and
that parallel system which is bitcoin i
think it's inevitable
is is as people are starting to
understand what you've been saying for a
long time what i've been saying for a
lot of people have been saying for a
long time they're building that parallel
system and that parallel system on
bitcoin is getting stronger and stronger
and stronger and it's moving at a
velocity it was building on top of that
is going to
remake the world under under a system
that looks more like a free market yeah
what's fascinating about this is uh
there's a gentleman mark spitznagel who
runs a fund
and the whole idea is he loses money
every day by buying uh you know
basically out of the money options
betting on a market downturn and so he
loses money sometimes for years uh and
um
when there is a market downturn he's the
best performing hedge fund and he
basically catches up and then passes
everybody and so in fact i think it was
february march of 2020 he returned like
4 400 percent right
and uh he has a book uh the dow of
capital and i always tell folks it's
probably one of my favorite books to
read and in it uh he has a lot of
analogies and and kind of frameworks in
which he thinks about but one of them is
this idea of planting a special kind of
tree and the whole idea is over a long
period of time
it grows and it's very strong
and
that's similar to what bitcoin's doing
but the other piece of it is he
explicitly calls out the market
intervention and he says if every single
day you show up right and you're
constantly intervening in the markets
you distort all the price signals you
completely remove the free market and
what you actually do is as a human you
probably make the problems worse and
that's exactly what we're talking about
you do make the problems worse and then
all the because because they're people
are short-term in nature and they have
mandates for four years and they're
short-term and now i need to get elected
and you make the the problem cascades
way worse and they they miss all the
second third derivatives
of those problems which are and a lot of
monetary monetary theories like
ask right now what does monetary
modern monetary theory look like where
you can just print money ask those
people right now what what just happened
with russia saying
we're not pricing
us dollars and so
you
if you're a nation state that controls
the
currency of the world
and somebody else wants to price their
raw materials that you need in something
else
it's checkmate
when you think of that um
bitcoin i think is uh probably the only
way out for a lot of folks uh in this
environment uh how do you see bitcoin
playing out and why do you see it as the
only way out
um
when i wrote my book and i
i only had a paragraph on bitcoin in in
my book but because i wanted to talk
about the structural issues and then a
potential way out but i have been
looking i've been talking about this for
10 plus years
and
trying to find
a way out of this and really for my kids
for for for
and
and
you
probably
the simplest way i could explain this is
throughout history same thing ray dalio
talks about you could just say if
if
a money could be corrupted
for some people's gains
over some people's expense
negative positive externalities negative
externalities um it will be
not it might be it will be for sure and
history proves it
seizing of gold
uh changing of of the rules of gold
history proves that that will happen
always and it's because human nature is
inside that state we care about
ourselves first
rather than some far-off land
and so so
we will do that humans will do that if a
money can be controlled
habitually is the only thing that i've
seen that removes that
temptation or power from us our human
nature
to
compete against other people and and and
it's kind of a profound thing because it
moves
global competition to global cooperation
and
a different shelling point
um and and
and assuming that stays true bitcoin
remains decentralized which i suspect it
will
um and and then it's out of the hands of
people to be able to manipulate it now
when i people say okay well why prices
are going down manipulation
um on on bitcoin if more and more people
are buying
there are people
creating leveraged products on bitcoin
today and some of the exchanges some of
the exchanges will fail on bitcoin and
when this price goes
make sure make sure you hold bitcoin on
your own private wallet and your own own
own keys
um because
over time when this thing goes parabolic
it's going to take out a whole bunch of
uh exchanges that are levered and you're
going to see you're going to see what
happens because bitcoin doesn't care it
doesn't have that counterparty risk
unless you impose that counterparty risk
by
by leveraging yourself under somebody's
else's exchange
but but that decentralization
and taking that money out of control of
human nature
means
we're forced to cooperate
and and
in
labor we we'll often miss that the buyer
and seller
are actually the same person
so all of our labor
shows up as somebody buying our labor
and but but because we miss that so we
miss that we can use zoom now for
effectively free
and that removed a whole bunch of other
businesses
because because now that our that
message can transfer
touch millions of people all over the
world essentially for
for free
and
yet we don't want prices to fall over
we want our house prices to go up
forever
yet all the things we choose in our
lives we want more value in
so we miss that it's the same thing
right all of our labor is somebody
else's buying and and so we but we but
we want all of our things we choose to
go down in price yet we want our assets
to go up in price
and and that's because of the system
that wouldn't look like that system
prices of housing would fall to the
utility value
they wouldn't be used as a store of
value
in a in a market that that didn't
require leverage and leverage and
leverage
and and so so all of these prices as
technology removed labor
would fall in in lockstep that's why i
say it would be the most the broadest
distribution of tech winners would we
would still compete to create products
which still create to create
great great technology that and the only
way to win would be to delivering value
to somebody else in their terms that's
the only way to get more bitcoin
um in their terms and out and they in
the in the what would happen out of that
is prices would fall everybody would win
so that's the world we're moving to it's
going to be chaotic on the way on the
way there if you're if you're living in
bitcoin if you're managing your world in
bitcoin right now what you're seeing is
prices against bitcoin fall
forever every price falls forever but if
you're measuring your world in a in in a
fiat currency you're thinking prices are
going to rise forever hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time